Rick's trout's been all over this he
covers the Buccaneers for the Tampa Bay
Times Rick how do you think Buccaneer
fans are feeling right now after that
news from Tom Brady yeah I'll make it
easy for you hell yeah you know this is
a franchise that hasn't been relevant
since 2002 when they won the Super Bowl
they've missed the playoffs and by a lot
12 straight years so TB 12 and TB
yeah I mean that they're all about it
now you know we can't have nice things
right that's that's the whole thing in
Tampa
you know the hockey team wins the
Presidents Trophy and loses in four
games the you know the Rays win 97 and
now they're talking about going to
Montreal so you know everybody's sort of
like if you're a fan here you don't want
to give your heart to this but from an
organizational standpoint I mean I would
just say this you know consider it Bruce
Arians
having coached Peyton Manning Ben
Roethlisberger Carson Palmer Andrew Luck
when Tom Brady you know starts asking
around and he looks at this football
team if it's a football decision I think
it's an easy one now the Chargers are
one year removed you know from being 12
and five
I don't know Anthony Lin that well I
mean you know LA it's his home state but
I've kind of felt for a while that you
know that the Bucs are really a place
that he could end up and I know it
sounds ridiculous in some ways the
Patriots to the box but that's where
we're at
but also I'm trying to figure that when
Tampa is all in or at least that's the
report all in and I think you had this
report was but it's all in mean they're
not gonna be outbid in terms of salary I
mean they had almost you know over 80
million dollars in salary cap space that
probably went up a little bit you know
like I said I think what it means is
they're going to make as good of a pitch
as they could possibly make if he wants
you know if he's worried about the
offense okay it's too vertical not
enough protection I want to do I want to
run what I do I don't think that's going
to be a problem for Bruce Arians Bruce
Arians is coach
a longtime Byron Leftwich will work with
Brady for game planning purposes you
know Clyde Christiansen was Peyton
Manning's offensive coordinator after
Tony Dungy left they went to a Super
Bowl and and Peyton Brand Peyton's
office now obviously they were going to
change it but my point is it's it's a
it's something he could get if he if he
wanted you know a slot receiver that you
know could work underneath like Edelman
or somebody like that I mean they would
they would work with him to try to make
him comfortable but there's already lots
of weapons here and they're going to
draft the offensive lineman maybe your
running back that can catch so you know
the defense last six weeks were among
the best in the NFL those young guys
grew up they really signed Jason
pierre-paul they franchised Shaq Barrett
who led the league in sacks there are
some football pieces here but it's Tampa
Bay you know it's like great place to
live all those things that's that's what
I mean they're going to sell him but
mostly if he comes I think it's going to
be because of Bruce Arians is Jameis
Winston the starting quarterback in the
NFL in your opinion I think he's gonna
have to work his way back to that Dan
you know he's got talent it is no doubt
about it I mean the guy can absolutely
rip the ball down the field the problem
is and I've had to describe to me you
know he's a slow twitch guy in a quick
twitch position he doesn't make
decisions fast enough at times you know
most of the throws that get him in
trouble are you know underneath and and
and he doesn't give up on plays when he
should at times he's a talented guy
works his ass off he deserves to start
miss league he's one of the top thirty
two quarterbacks I have no doubt about
that but he may have to you know go the
Ryan Tannehill route and maybe back up a
wobbly starter somewhere and when he
gets his chance you know light it up
what's plan B for the Buccaneers if you
whip on Tom Brady well I think you're
gonna go from T b12 to TB v teddy
bridgewater any Bridgewater yeah which
is a big you know kind of a shot to
stomach when you look at it that way but
but but Teddy did a good job against him
last year you know they played the
Saints he threw for three hundred and
four touchdowns so remember Bruce Arians
coming in after that game
saying man I love Teddy and he should be
a starter in this league well you know
he may have to give him that opportunity
are you here to guarantee that the next
quarterback and the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
will have the initials TB I think so
I think you know TV 5 TV 12 for Tampa
Bay you know it's a it's made to order
Dan I think they have to just go ahead
and start filling the number later you
know just put the TV there and but I'm
worried this is what I'm worried about
with Brady does Brady look good in those
Tampa Bay uniforms that's well here's
the thing Dan I mean and they must have
been you know anticipating this because
you're changing them they're changing
the uniform can you imagine him walking
out or hell maybe gizelle you know
modeling the new ones I mean they're
going back to the getting rid of the
alarm clock numbers that was a bad idea
yeah and they're going back to the the
Super Bowl you know block letters more
traditional uniforms I think the
creamsicle fits Brady Rickey Bell Doug
Williams creamsicle but you know people
hated him when they were losing it if we
win but Rick when you win it's amazing
how good a uniform looks I'm telling you
yeah it won't matter what uniform you
wear as if it's Tom Brady he looks good
in anything right do you think that
there's a decision by the end of the
week with Tom Brady I think that they'll
have to be what you know you can't
really sign with anybody I think until
what Wednesday or yeah but I yeah I
think buddy in a week look these teams
need to know I mean Teddy Bridgewater
you know is gonna have an opportunity to
go someplace we thought he was going to
be a bear why didn't we see that coming
teddy bear no but but it turned out that
you know they're going another way and I
imagine that Bridgewater
to some extent Winston look it's not out
of the question okay that Jameis comes
back here if he goes out can't find a
starting job with starters money the
Bucks strike out in some free agents you
know they may have them back but right
now I know it sounds weird but Tom Brady
I've guaranteed that the Buccaneers are
making the
I just don't know if I can continue to
make that bet if Jameis Winston's the
starting quarterback I have to retract
that yeah I don't know you could I mean
you know he's been here five years he
would have made it under the new rules
owed and it and everybody make the
playoffs pretty heavily well he's our 14
teams no I know I know I think he may
even made it tell you what he would have
made it back in what was it seven 16
when they were 9 and 7 under than under
the new rules where everybody gets in so
you know yeah he'd have a shot he's not
gonna throw 30 well he he comes back 30
touchdowns or 30 interceptions 2024 2020
that's a motto now with his new vision
and everything I love that he gets
everybody involved offense defense the
opposition everybody gets involved with
I think he's the most fascinating player
in the NFL because I and not in a good
way
I can't take my eyes I can't take my
eyes off James Winston when he's out
there hey just remember Jon Gruden used
to talk about quarters they get a what
it's like a right on the secret man you
know I mean over the place I mean it is
you can't look down to get a you know a
freaking glass of water without seeing
somebody running with the ball somewhere
so he is exciting and he has talent and
I and I really do believe this I think
he'll play 15 years and you know find
himself in a Super Bowl I don't know if
it's the way Doug Williams did it or
turned over or what but everybody that
leaves Tampa as you know the quarterback
you got to go to a Super Bowl good pole
on the Jon Gruden impersonation there I
like that yeah six years listen to John
more than Frank thank you Rick will be
reading will be following thank you for
joining us that's Rick Stroud he covers
the Buccaneers for the Tampa Bay Times